este cartel en el que se ve este perro
este Jack Russell Terrier que se ha
convertido en el símbolo de Ucrania uno
de los símbolos y Héroes de la guerra
llama la atención sobre uno de los
factores que más preocupan en este
momento en el país y eso las
consecuencias de las minas
antipersonales que quedan en muchas de
las regiones que han estado en control
de las tropas rusas y que hoy vuelven a
estar en control de las tropas
ucranianas este perro se ha convertido
en un símbolo porque no solamente ha
destinado muchísimas regiones sino que
llama la atención de muchísimos niños y
por eso este cartel en el cual se dice
que se encuentran algo abandonado por
favor no se acerquen no lo toquen y
llamen a los servicios de emergencia Y
es que
los muertos no solamente civiles sino
militares que quedan como consecuencia
de las minas crecen todos los días en el
país el otro día nos contaba una
integrante en una zona del Bosque en la
región del Don vast decenas de sus
compañeros habían fallecido como
consecuencia de estas Minas y días atrás
también cuatro policías en la región de
gersón murieron como consecuencia de lo
mismo estaban realizando tareas de
destinado y murieron como consecuencia
de esto y lo mismo ha pasado incluso con
trabajadores de las redes ferroviarias
que cuando llegan a arreglar el servicio
de trenes también o no han fallecido
pero se han perdido sus piernas y han
quedado gravemente heridos Así que el
país Libra una gran campaña de llamar la
atención a la población sobre las minas
y sobre todo el peligro que representa
entrar a un lugar que no ha estado
revisado anteriormente por los servicios
de emergencia